[Musica]
è questo qui secondo me è un modo molto
carino per iniziare fatemi sapere anzi
se sono riuscito a terrorizzarvi perché
se vi ho terrorizzato che ho raggiunto
un grandissimo traguardo autoriale va
beh il video di oggi parla delle fisse e
io ammetto di aver avuto di avere tante
fisse e una di queste era tipo fare
fingere da un momento all'altro di stare
un film horror e problemi che di fissi
io non ne ho altri vi farò un bel elenco
di quelle che sono quelle più forti è
una sorta di confessione a cuore aperto
uno sputtanamento ci posso fare
[Musica]
uno dell'eni fissa e stare a dieta in
generale anche se mangio buonasera
allora vorrei olive ascolane una
margherita
cosa a quel momento una panna cotta al
cioccolato e basta no no la coca cola
zero e che si chieda
[Musica]
c'era un periodo nel quale adoravo in
anime e volevo studiare la lingua
giapponese
[Musica]
[Applauso]
forse tutti e due stili di sì il
problema è che non ho mai imparato una
parola in giapponese
un'altra fissa che ho avuto è quella di
vendere tutto quanto quello che avessi
ogni qualsiasi cosa io possedessi per
diventare ricco su ebay annunci
[Musica]
grazie ho sempre sognato di acquistare
questo telefono
[Musica]
solo e ho sempre voluto sta per lucca
sempre con una pantofola e basta ho
sempre voluto acquistare questo vaso
orribile
[Musica]
ho sempre sognato questo ritratto maria
rabboni ho avuto una fissa comunque per
magico
mai sentito no
[Applauso]
ho avuto una fissa con l'interpretariato
guarda veramente non so che impattano
sono più contenute per esempio stupido
io sono qua ha anche smentito
smettila stop è creata la fissa che
fissava il frigo una fissa ambigua la
fissa di parlare davanti al ventilatore
la fissa di parlare con gli animali
facendo i loro versi mi risponde mi sto
parlando lato lingua
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la fissa di fare le prove del discorso
della mia vittoria dell'oscar davanti
allo specchio
ed è per questo che per me è un
grandissimo onore vincere questo premio
ringrazio i miei ringrazio raffaele
l'interazione adrien e ringrazio tutti i
miei amici
daniel con lei
sempre statici e il cuore mio vi
ringrazio veramente spero che
lo si possa raggiungere non pagherà in
qualsiasi cosa per la pace remo grassi
e queste sogni fisse mi sono rovinato
quali solo perché altre le vostre fatelo
sapere così in un commentino perché non
è giusto che io mi sfruttarli anzi
fatemelo sapere un video risposta così
mi sputtana tepore voi e se proprio non
volete sputtanarvi vabbè per una volta
via bono l'animato su youtube
oh ma nessuno si compra mia nonna
vabbè prendiamo con il fratello